hi Jason how are you I'm Dave how you
better than I deserve
how can I help I've got myself a mess
I'm an attorney but I have my own shop
it's where I got about $400,000 in debt
I'm working for a new firm now so I've
steady income koala taxes to the bones
looking at in chapter 13 which should be
starting shortly to my questions one you
should I do that
and number two if I do that how can I
save money to so that when I come up in
a bit limit in better spots
what's your income okay and break the
four hundred thousand and debt down for
me what's it what's it out against
fifteen is too long about portal jury's
back taxes to the IRS employment taxes
from the five thousand in business line
of credit
twenty thousand or credit cards the
vehicles that were being stupid ones
already after there's one already did
some other random death you're single
and recently had last year so a divorce
yep and you had a hard couple years here
brother okay chapter 13 is a payment
plan as you know okay so I don't know
what it really benefits you I mean you
could put the IRS on a payment plan and
move them to the front of your debt
snowball you can ignore the credit cards
for a while they're gonna crash your
credit but not as much as a chapter 13
does you can sell off the vehicles the
ones already gone and you're due
with a repo collection there which you
pay nothing on for right now and so you
know if you just say I'm going to list
these off by importance and begin to
attack them in that order put the
student loan on hardship deferral with
the taxes at the top of your list and
pay them off very very very quickly like
I don't know eight months you'd be done
with the IRS easy making the money
you're making just put yourself on beans
and rice rice and beans right and then
go through and the vehicles are gone
clean up your credit cards and then you
can go settle with the vehicle if you've
been repo one of them got repo'd or what
okay and the other one you're driving
right I am and what's that one how much
do you owe on it
okay sell it get you a beater that gets
rid of that debt the repo'd one the
balance is all they're coming after you
on the deficit balance the difference
between what you was owed and what they
sold it for and you can settle that for
a quarter on the dollar in cash later so
I don't know that a chapter 13
necessarily benefits you I think you'll
be out of debt faster and without as
much damage to your credit just working
a prioritized plan through this and I
would my plan would be taxes first line
of credit or credit cards second the
other one-third you know clear up the
vehicle debt with with a settlement and
then start the student loans and begin
to work through those because you know
that's all you're gonna do with the
chapter 13 anyway is just wander through
this stuff of the night chapter 13 60
months it's five months you're going to
be in that and I think you can do it you
know if you've got enough emotional
energy left in your tank after all the
hell you've been through to fight
through this I think you can do it more
efficiently without the thirteen
personally this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]